speaking by the way of drugs
donald trump jr was now asked when he
was on fox and friends yesterday morning
whether his tirade speech at the
republican national convention on monday
night
was filled by cocaine and he has since
denied it now
um last night was night three of the
republican national convention but if
you think back to the first night there
were many questions raised about the
insanity of donald trump jr speech
and also the speech of his girlfriend
kimberly guilfoyle the content was of
course completely unhinged
but the delivery also raised questions
about upper use
because both don jr and kimberly
guilfoyle
seemed completely shot out of cannons
kimberly guilfoyle screaming
uncontrollably which we'll get to don jr
his eyes almost swollen completely shut
almost like a frothing at the mouth
delivery
well donald trump jr is now denying that
his speech was fueled by cocaine and
this is one of those things where if
you're even talking about this
maybe there's a problem here is don jr
himself answering the questions about
this yesterday on fox and friends
you were one of the keynote speakers on
the first night monday night
and speaking of the media i afterwards i
i saw that the main concern was why were
his eyes so glassy
well i i guess there must have been
something with the lighting but they
started doing this trending thing
donald trump jr's own cocaine and all
that i said
no no you have me confused with hunter
biden
oh it was it was pretty ridiculous you
know so when they can't attack the
delivery when they can't attack the
substance
they gotta attack something just like
bette midler uh
and all of these woke hollywoodites last
night attacking melania
because she didn't speak english the
same way that they would well she speaks
five languages she's from a foreign
country she got up on a world stage
and knocked it out of the park but you
know what attack her
it's ridiculous it's the same as
watching the dnc attacking the rnc
because the rnc has
the gall to showcase real americans
who have benefited for donald trump's
policies who have benefited from this
administration
rather than the out-of-touch hollywood
celebrities
that they put on their never-ending zoom
call
uh of i hate america last week uh it's
truly mind-boggling how out of touch
the democrats are they don't even see it
it's asinine
notice that don jr doesn't say i've
never done cocaine or i don't do
cocaine he simply says i was not on coke
that night
but hunter biden was something about the
lighting made him look like maybe he was
on coke i guess
uh and the more i think about it if i
were a public figure
and someone asked me about an interview
during an interview about whether
i was on cocaine during a speech and if
it was really bogus
i don't think i would dignify it with a
response i don't know about you
i would say that's absolutely absurd
it's being asserted without evidence
and i'm not even going to dignify that
with a response
uh there's also video from before don jr
went on of him drinking
two red bulls so maybe it's just red
bull maybe it was red bull and something
else i don't know but take a look at
this
guys donald trump jr here super excited
first night of the rnc
2020 getting amped up and ready for my
speech it's gonna be awesome
now just a reminder here's one of the
most unhinged moments from don jr speech
just so you know
this has not been sped up or in any way
you'll notice
if you're watching don junior's swollen
eyes and just a lot of other weird
details
imagine the life you want to have one
with a great job
a beautiful home a perfect family you
can have it
imagine the country you want to live in
one with true
equal opportunity where hard work pays
off and justice is served with
compassion and without partiality
you can have it imagine a world where
the evils of communism and radical
islamic terrorism
are not given a chance to spread where
heroes are celebrated and the good guys
win
you can have it that is the
life that is the country that is the
world that donald trump and the
republican party are after
and yes you can have it
because unlike joe biden and the radical
left democrats
our party is open to everyone
it starts by rejecting radicals who want
to drag us into the dark
and embracing the man who represents
a bright and beautiful future for all
and then even more outrageously here is
kimberly guilfoyle just screaming at the
top of her lungs
ladies and gentlemen leaders and
fighters for freedom and liberty
and the american dream the best
is yet to come
so if lighting is the only explanation i
want to talk to the gaffer and see how
he was able to achieve that look but
here's here's what i really want to
focus on
first of all it's insane that this is
even something that's being discussed
fine but more importantly
isn't it really weird that when don jr
was asked about it he doesn't deny using
cocaine he says it was the lights and
hunter biden actually does cocaine
i find that to be a really strange
reaction and then
the top level thought that i had was
i consider drug addiction to be a
medical issue it's not something we
laugh at
it's not something we make fun of and
when don jr makes this comment about
hunter biden
uh hunter biden has spoken about
living with drug addiction and don jr
is essentially making fun of someone in
recovery
from drug addiction and that's really
the disgust the most disgusting
aspect of this so this entire episode is
another
confirmation that money can't really buy
class
and that an expensive education also
doesn't guarantee
empathy both things that we probably
knew before the trump presidency
but have been made even more clear but
in any case
for all of you who emailed me about what
don and kimberly were on
monday night he denies that it was
cocaine
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this
is not a random doctor on call each
doctor
at steady md has a limited number of
patients so they actually have time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video